Dieses Video muss jeder Vater sehen.
Und eigentlich auch jede Mutter.
Und jede Tochter,
und jeder Sohn, jeder.
Jeder muss dieses Video sehen, okay?
*Titelmusik*
Wisst ihr noch,
vor nicht allzulanger Zeit,
ging dieses Video hier viral,
wo ein BBC-Interview
mit einem Politikprofessor
von dessen Kindern gecrasht wurde.
Dazu gab es u.a. diese Parodie,
wo die Mutter- und Vaterrolle
vertauscht wurde
und die Mutter als Multitasking-
Superhero dargestellt wird.
Während der Vater am Ende vom Video
noch an einer
einzelnen Socke verzweifelt.
Ich fand diese Parodie
damals so witzig,
dass sie sie immerhin
selbst geteilt hatte.
Aber jetzt mal Spaß beiseite.
Wir leben in einer Zeit,
in der Mütter als Powerfrauen
der Familie gefeiert werden
und Väter, die...
...sind halt auch da.
Früher war das so,
der Mann ist der "Mann im Haus",
verdient das Geld und ist deswegen
eigentlich auch nie im Haus.
Die Frau ist die Hausfrau und Mama
und kümmert sich um die Kinder.
Heute ist das anders,
je weniger Männern der Alphastempel
aufgedrückt wird, desto eher werden
sie auch als Väter wahrgenommen.
Aber nicht wirklich
als gleichberechtigtes Elternteil.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht,
aber in meiner
sozialen Filterblase
werden Väter als zwar liebevolle
aber auch irgendwie unbeholfene
und bisschen verpeilte
Typen dargestellt,
die zwar ganz gut
mit Kindern spielen können -
aber für die Erziehung
sind die nicht wirklich gemacht.
Im Internet werden Väter
derzeit ermüdend oft mit "Dadjokes"
in Verbindung gebracht.
Väter sind also
für schlechte Wortwitze gut.
Aber wenn's dann mal ernst wird,
dann muss die Mama eingreifen.
Wir haben nicht nur den Eindruck,
dass Mama besser
für die Erziehung gemacht ist,
sondern dass Mama auch viel
wichtiger ist für die Erziehung.
Nicht selten wird eine Frau
schief angeschaut,
wenn die z.B. nur einen kleinen Teil
ihrer Elternzeit nimmt.
Rabenmutter.
Und leider ist es auch nicht selten,
dass Männer
schief angeschaut werden,
wenn sie einen Großteil
der Elternzeit nehmen wollen.
Hä? Was willst du denn zu Hause?
Unten habe ich euch
einen Review-Artikel verlinkt,
der 36 wissenschaftliche Studien
aus aller Welt vergleicht
und zu dem Schluss kommt,
dass Vater- und Mutterliebe
gleich wichtig sind.
In manchen Fällen
wird sogar beobachtet,
dass die Vaterrolle
eine größere Rolle spielt.
Möglicherweise weil Männer
mit mehr Macht und Respekt
assoziiert werden,
was sich auf die Wahrnehmung
der Eltern übertragen kann.
Das Gefühl der Ablehnung
oder Zurückweisung hat einen
der stärksten Einflüsse auf die
gesunde Entwicklung eines Kindes.
Ein Gefühl der Ablehnung
kann bereits durch einen Mangel
an Aufmerksamkeit entstehen.
Zum Beispiel wenn die Mutter
oder eben der Vater sich zu wenig
in die Kindeserziehung
mit einbringt.
Erleben wir Ablehnung,
werden dieselben
Gehirnsregionen aktiviert,
wie bei physischem Schmerz.
Doch im Gegensatz
zu physischem Schmerz
kann der Schmerz einer Ablehnung
noch Jahre später
immer wieder durchlebt werden.
Und glauben wir den Studien,
dann hat insbesondere die Vaterliebe
einen großen Einfluss
auf die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
ob die Kinder später
an Depressionen erkranken,
oder ob sie
zu Drogenkonsum neigen.
Oft spricht man ja davon, wie
wichtig Vaterrollen für Jungs sind.
Weswegen v.a. in Kindergärten
und in Grundschulen
ein besonders großer Bedarf
an männlichen Mitarbeitern besteht.
Doch auch wenn Väter,
statistisch gesehen,
mehr Zeit mit ihren Söhnen
verbringen als mit ihren Töchtern,
sind sie für die Entwicklung
ihrer Töchter nicht weniger wichtig.
Unter "Daddy Issues"
beschreibt man umgangssprachlich
die Promiskuität einer Frau,
die die Aufmerksamkeit,
die sie damals
bei ihrem Vater vermisste,
in einer Vielzahl
von Affären wieder sucht.
Zuerst mal würde das
ja voraussetzen, dass Promiskuität
ausschließlich auf ein geringes
Selbstwertgefühl zurückzuführen ist.
Und das nur bei Frauen.
Ich gehe jetzt mal davon aus,
dass Promiskuität auch auf Spaß,
Einverständnis
und Respekt beruhen kann.
Die Wissenschaft sagt hier
folgendes: die Art und Weise,
wie der Vater, die Mutter,
oder auch die Töchter behandelt,
prägt sehr stark
die Vorstellung der Töchter,
was eine "normale" Beziehung
zwischen Mann und Frau ist.
Sehr oft, wenn auch nicht bewusst,
orientieren sich Frauen
in ihrer Partnerwahl
am eigenen Vater.
Außerdem beobachtete man
eine erhöhte Anzahl
an Jugendschwangerschaften
bei Frauen,
die eine schlechte Beziehung
zu ihrem Vater hatten.
Auf der anderen Seite
beobachtete man bei Frauen,
die ihre Beziehung
zum Vater als warm, liebevoll
und kommunikativ beschrieben,
dass sie im Durchschnitt
später heirateten
und auch später Kinder bekamen.
Das mag auch daran liegen,
dass Väter,
die akademischen und beruflichen
Karrieren ihrer Töchter
ziemlich stark beeinflussen können.
Im Gegensatz zu den Siebzigern
ist es heutzutage
dreimal wahrscheinlicher, dass
Frauen im selben Berufsfeld landen,
wie ihre Väter.
Ich bin das beste Beispiel dafür,
ohne meinen Papa hätte ich wahr-
scheinlich kein Chemie studiert.
Frauen in Führungspositionen
haben überdurchschnittlich oft
ein gesundes Verhältnis
zu ihrem Vater.
Und, interessanterweise,
oft keine Brüder,
mit denen sie sich die Aufmerksam-
keit des Vaters teilen mussten.
Ich will damit nicht sagen,
dass Väter unentbehrlich sind.
Auch gleichgeschlechtliche Paare
und Alleinerziehende können genauso
gesunde und glückliche Kinder
erziehen wie klassische Familien.
Auch dazu gibt es
wissenschaftliche Studien.
Ich will damit nur sagen,
dass Väter viel wichtiger sind
als viele von uns bewusst oder
unterbewusst wahrscheinlich glauben.
Wenn wir Männern immer sagen,
dass sie nicht so gute Eltern
sein können, wie Mütter,
ist das genauso,
als würden wir Mädchen sagen,
dass sie nicht so gut in Mathe
sein können, wie Jungs.
Wir geben dadurch Wege vor,
die manche oder vielleicht sogar
viele gar nicht einschlagen würden.
Dabei gibt es doch
keinen wichtigeren Job
als die Erziehung unserer Kinder.
Also die Gestaltung
unserer zukünftigen Gesellschaft.
Oder nicht?
Schön schlau.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2017)
Und damit geht ganz viel Liebe
nach draußen an alle Väter
und Mütter, v.a. natürlich an meine
Eltern, die beide der Hammer sind.
Ich wünsche euch
einen schönen Vatertag
und schreibt mir doch bitte,
was ihr zu dem Thema denkt.
Es interessiert mich wirklich sehr.
Wir sehen uns nächsten Donnerstag,
bis dahin, bleibt sicher.